[Music]
we're both pasty fellas I got your beet
dude you do have me again
yeah a dad's a one step away from my
albinos you know what is funny on the
internet they are that's true
you laughing at me or the oral albinos I
get a lot of tweets what they're telling
me that redheads are dying off really
yeah they tell me that do you know you
guys are gonna be gonna studies have
shown one of my favorite things that you
hear in bars studies have shown that
redheads gonna be gonna die off by like
20 40 or so they don't even think it's
like my friend just had a redheaded baby
do you have some sort of final solution
for all right you're gonna whack that
kid when he's like 19 yo yo you'll never
get rid of red ever since that South
Park episode what they did all that dead
ginger thing just like the level of hate
like I'm so glad I my dad is over I
already got enough of it and now it did
just come in like full force and the
amount of people who come up to me brown
blonde black hair who are not
good-looking people
horrific horrific looking people and
they just think that there's somehow a
cut above me it just really irks me I
did great when I was single I did great
okay did not have an issue you already
come on to me I'm just looking at it's
like dude you felt your face you already
you're already settling into that
Winston Churchill jowl look like
you need 22 should never you can't where
you have a beard where your jawline
should be that's my favorite I don't
have I don't have any sympathy for fat
people by the way that's another one I
don't know that's dead where are they on
kick it ginger day huh they send me a
card
they don't people only care about their
group that's it I've noticed that
they're doing stand up defeat when you
when you make fun of animals the people
who get offended is the animal people
right if you make you make fun of ages
the Asians come up you make fun of this
right but the Asian people never never
defend the fatties right the fat people
never go hey lay off those Chihuahua
jokes they dumb it's just it's very
selfish where they'll sit there and just
subject after subject they're all
laughing and the second it comes to
their neighborhood it's it's not jokes
anymore these these these statements
[Applause]
[Music]